David Cay Johnston book called the
making of Donald Trump is your latest
and you say in the book that in the
spring of 2016 you talk to mr. Trump on
the phone what was that about
well I was writing a piece for Politico
magazine about all of Donald's
connections to a very major drug
trafficker who supplied him with his
helicopters to con artists swindlers
American Mafia Russian mobsters and
Donald had been sent an email by me
asking if you want to comment with about
20 points and he called me and the
essence of the conversation was you know
you wrote a lot of things I like Dave
but if I don't like what you're right
I'm going to sue you I've from covering
the Santa Cruz City Council in
California 50 years ago to today it's
the only politician who's ever
threatened to sue me unless I write what
he wants and I said well Donnell your
public figure that means he would have
to prove I deliberately lied and knew it
and he goes I know I'm a public figure
I'll see you anyway and I think this is
indicative of Donald's character and his
authoritarian approach you do it the way
I want it or I will make life difficult
for you but what do you remember
reacting to when he said that what was
your people friend this to me a lot of
times it just goes with the job
1988 in Atlantic City is saying if met
him for the first time what were the
circumstances well I had left the Los
Angeles Times where I'd spent 12 years
to go to Atlantic City for the
Philadelphia Inquirer I believed we were
going to see casino gaming spread all
across America which it did and I wanted
to examine whether government really
could clean up this business that was
traditionally run by Vice Lords and
crooks and within a couple of days I met
Donald I immediately recognized Brian
that he speak to you Bart
he's selling you tickets to the Fiji
mermaid and the amazing two-headed woman
and then I started because he was the
dominant force Atlantic City I started
asking about him and his competitors
including Steve Wynn and people who
worked for him and some big gamblers all
said to me Naaman doesn't know anything
about the casino business oh come on
how could he not know anything about the
casino business they said that all he
knows is how to extract money from the
casino he doesn't know how to manage
custom
he doesn't know how to reinvest in the
properties doesn't have a developed
customers etc so Donald I had a cup of
coffee not long after that and I asked
him a question about craps and I
deliberately made a false statement and
Donald immediately incorporated my
falsehood into his answer
what's a con artists do that's what the
the psychics advertised on daytime TV do
so I had a couple more questions that I
asked him where I made false statements
and he immediately embraced them and I
realized what I was being told was true
Donald doesn't know anything it's all
bluster it's all appearance it's all
threats he's quick he's smart but he's
not at all studious or deep and in the
book I quote testimony where he gives
answers to questions one of them my
students at Syracuse University who are
law third-year law and graduate business
students at the end of my course can
answer the question like this anyone
who's been to the Wharton Business
School can answer like this Donald's
answer is gibberish he doesn't
understand the most basic issues of
Finance and listen how he answers
questions you ask him what's your
favorite bible verse because he says no
one reads the Bible more than Donald
Trump because there's so many there's so
many another there's just so many back
in 1968 he appeared on The Oprah Show it
may be it I think 6850 a that just shows
you my age back in 88 28 years ago what
I think well first of all that was the
year he asked George HW Bush to make him
his running mate as vice president and
said Dan Quayle got the job Donald has
been talking about running for president
since 1985 and 12 years later in 2000 he
ran and he said I'm going to be the
first person to run for president and
make a profit so this is indicative of
Donald Donald will tell you whatever he
thinks is in his interest at the moment
that's what con artists do they tell you
whatever is in their interests whatever
they think you want to hear and what
will get you to do whatever it is they
want what are your own politics
well I'm a registered Republican before
that I was registered in tom golisano's
party in New York but I'm not a
political person I voted for people on
every line that's ever appeared on a
ballot I'm on four different offices
I don't like politics this is the one of
only two campaigns in the last 40 years
I've covered I did for the LA Times the
governor's race in 1976 and Nevada and
hated covering I don't like covering
politics I'm a policy guy I am someone
who believes that we should be using the
government for the purposes the six
noble purposes in the preamble to
establish justice promote the general
welfare and in fact I'm developing I
hope a new course to teach at the
Syracuse which is how we got the
Constitution and what it's about in
context you say in the book that the
Trump family really haven't been voters
yes interestingly two of Donald's
children did not get to vote for him
because they hadn't registered as
Republicans and they then complained
about the rules well New York has
archaic awful terrible election rules
but they should have known this and
they're real ones who are responsible
for doing this Donald hasn't voted in a
bunch of elections and by the way Donald
and Dell very recently was basically a
Democrat and one of the things Don
believes in which is a good thing in my
view is universal health care we should
get health care off the backs of
business and it should be as he says a
public good provided to everybody that's
certainly not a Republican Party
position give us some background on
yourself where did you grow up I was
born in San Francisco I consider home to
be Santa Cruz California my father was a
hundred percent disabled veteran of
World War two my mother was a disowned
heiress and I had the odd experience of
growing up in a house on a cliff over
the beach that my parents rented for
maybe $400 a month in today's money
nothing what do you mean by disowned
heiress she testified against her father
in a lawsuit in 1941 when he was sued
for alienation of affection and his only
child my mother was disowned and he was
a very wealthy man and so I went to work
when I was ten years old I went to work
full-time at 13 I became a reporter for
some weekly papers at 17 and my work
immediately got noticed because I did
some simple things if the school board
said the average owner the owner the
average thirty four thousand three
hundred and fourteen dollar house in
and occurs next year we'll pay $42 and
11 cents more in property taxes I
thought that was useless so with long
division I said you'll pay so much more
per thousand in the value of your house
at 18 the San Jose Mercury recruited me
at 19 I was right in front page stories
and the San Jose Mercury is a staff
writer and I went to the Detroit I went
to the University of Chicago graduate
school of economics as a fellow for two
quarters to the Detroit Free Press the
LA Times filled up Inquirer the New York
Times and then just short of 40 years of
daily reporting I left and since then
I've been a columnist and an author and
teaching at Syracuse University in the
College of Law I live in Rogers live in
Rochester my wife runs the very
successful Community Foundation there
and in Rochester New York we had the
best child care in all the United States
Canada and Western Europe and it cost
this much more than warehousing kids
very smart program that she's in the
between Bolton a couple of weeks ago
Donald Trump went to Tampa to give a
speech and when he got there this video
which was not done by him of course was
done by the folks that are opposed him
played on it's about 50 seconds see to
what you think so what's that all about
well Donald Trump had someone come to
him with what was a very good business
idea the man was in the business of
running continuing professional
education lawyers accountants real
estate agents have to go to courses to
make sure they're up on the law and he
went to Trump and said hey why don't we
do Trump real estate professional
education we charge a premium price a
brilliant business idea and Donald said
that's such a good idea I'm taking it
away from you
he gave the guy a little tiny stake I
think it was 3% and a quarter million
dollar salary and they decided then to
turn into Trump University well first of
all you can't call something a
university without a license from the
state and that's true and I believe
every state in the Union but every state
I've checked it is secondly this was not
a university in even the dictionary
meaning of the word and a Trump
University quickly came under
investigation as a scam people paid
fifteen hundred dollars and what they
got for that were high-pressure sales
tactics where the faculty would stand
over them and tell them how to call
banks and borrow more money and credit
cards so they could pay thirty five
thousand dollars
to get the full Trump University package
Donald did a promotional video Trump
University is all about success you're
going to have success we're going to
have the best faculty and adjunct
faculty they will be handpicked by me
the best of the very best you'll get a
better education that at the best
business schools and I know because I
went to the best one he didn't by the
way went to the undergraduate program a
Wharton not it's graduate program well
it turned out that the faculty knew
nothing about real estate they included
the manager of a fast food joint to
people in personal bankruptcy and a lot
of people with experience Brian in
high-pressure sales tactics as with
getting people to run up their debt and
by the way if you run up your debt and
borrowed as much as the bank's possibly
give you to pay for the Trump University
how would you have any borrowing
capacity to buy real estate so the New
York State Attorney General brought a
lawsuit over this bob was told to stop
using the word university he ignored it
for several years the Texas Attorney
General's Office did an investigation
and Pam Bondi the Attorney General of
Florida said publicly she was thinking
about joining New York investigation she
and Donnell had some kind of
communication they also the Trump Donald
J Trump Charitable Foundation then made
a campaign contribution to Pam Bondi now
charitable foundations cannot be
involved in political activity this
should cause the revocation of their
status as a non-profit the Bondi
campaign manager was asked about this
and the Florida newspapers reported that
we're perfectly comfortable with the
gift from the Donald J Trump foundation
which is astonishing Pam Bondi is a
lawyer she knows better than this
she also decided not to participate in
the New York Attorney General's
investigation and these this ad which is
pretty brutal is about fundamentally Pam
Bondi it's about the Attorney General
who accepted this gift and by the way
the Trump people tried to cover this up
they argued and I explained in my book
that it was money to go to a particular
group an anti-abortion group that
teaches people how to protest
against our current abortion laws they
didn't get any money that makes that it
was this outfit in California they
didn't get any money and they said wow
it was just a mistake well if it's a
mistake Pam Bondi should have given it
back I'm a should have directed the
money or other organizations they
haven't done any of that and he goes to
a core issue about Donald Donald has no
regard for whatever the law is he does
what he wants to do has he ever been
sued oh he's been sued according to USA
Today more than 4,500 times he's been
sued by workers he wouldn't pay and
there's a chapter in my book about that
he's been sued by vendors and he's been
sued by investors who say they've been
swindled and right now what's happened
after I finished the book a Benjamin
Moore paint dealer who supplied paint
for the remake of the Doral Country Club
that Donald owes wasn't paid the last
thirty four thousand dollars into a
little business like that thirty four
thousand dollars a big hunk of their
year's profits he sued he spent over
three hundred thousand dollars on legal
fees trying to collect his thirty four
thousand and the judge finally granted
this Benjamin Moore paint dealer the
power to foreclose on the Doral after
Donald Trump's witness testified about
why didn't you pay the thirty four
thousand your contract said you had to
pay mr. Trump feels he has paid enough
and Dom does this all the time he'll
take the work keeping for him he'll use
it and then he'll say I'm not going to
use this crap I'm not going to pay for
it and if you go to a lawyer and it's
$34,000 or even a hundred they'll tell
you even spend three hundred thousand
dollars on lawyers to fight Trump and
he's done this again and again and again
and again and again this book was
published by web publisher Melville
House press which is a little outfit in
Brooklyn and in London that do something
what I did my very first book would you
interviewed me about temples a chance
back in 1992 I complained back then my
publisher was doing everything on paper
and they were slow and they're efficient
I said somebody needs to make this
modern and quick and modernize the book
business these folks did it
Wikipedia say there's a liberal
publishing operation and you know
liberal conservative I don't care I mean
I don't pay any attention to the
politics of the people I work for
you know when I was at the LA Times they
ran editorials sometimes that basically
said don't believe what that guy wrote I
don't I don't care I tell the people I'm
writing for what I'm going to write even
when I was a reporter they never tell me
unless if it's breaking is no airplane
crash we need to be very right ma'am and
I would do that I tell them what I'm
going to do and I've always done that
and if you do that of course eventually
you we're at your welcome work if you
work where did you get the idea to do
this book and win well temple is a
chance I think all but one chapter has
some reference to Trump in it because he
was so dominant Atlantic City when
Donald announced on June 16th 2015 he
was running I got ahold of my literary
agent right away and said we should do a
book she called around every city not
going to get the nomination I said yes
he might get the nomination he's serious
this time and and I was particularly
charged up by the fact that here he is
giving this speech talking about
murderers and rapists from Mexico
denouncing Muslims and they're all these
young people are plotting these lines
and I thought Midtown Manhattan is not a
place known for racism and xenophobia
what did he do he's employees or did he
bust people in where'd he get this crowd
well day or two later The Hollywood
Reporter revealed that they were actors
paid 50 bucks each to show up and
applauded on cue which tells you what a
fraud
Donald Trump is and anyhow nobody won do
a book by the time it became clear he
might get the nomination for traditional
publishers who need about a year it was
too late
and I had just given up on the idea I
wrote about 25 pieces about Donald for
USA Today Newsweek national memo some
other places many of them aimed at
reporters trying to say this is what you
should be asking this is what you should
be questioning and then noble house
calls out of the blue and they asked
could we do the book in I think it was
three weeks I said no but I said I can
do it by a date that was four weeks
later I wrote that book in 27 days it
was hell and I'm frankly not sure I
physically recovered at my age from
doing it I'm certainly never going to do
it again but 27 days because we're in
the middle of the campaign 27 days it
was finished
a was that and well the my closing note
the epilogue is dated the fourth of July
actually finish the book the fifth of
July we finished editing at the 10th of
July and there's a picture on my
Facebook page of me sitting in my garden
reading the book on the 19th of July two
weeks later and I went on sale August
2nd two weeks after that and the German
language Edition went on sale August
thirtieth they had to translate into
German so lawyers top it and by the way
you call him on this very already a
conman and a fraud how how concerned was
a publisher that they pull the lawyers
in on this well sure this was vetted by
a lawyer and one of the things I don't
do in this book is I don't break new
ground in it because I knew we had to
get it lawyer quickly so what I've done
here is connected the dots and pulled
together my work the great Wayne
Barrett's work probably the best
reporter who ever worked in New York
City pieces elsewhere and I had this
enormous collection of cup documents I
used to have to rent to storage lockers
to hold my files on Donald Trump Barron
Hilton the LAPD Jack Welch and some
other people and now mostly got them
digitized but I had all these files and
so one of my grown children would sit in
the other room she created the file so
they were logical for me and after I was
done with them a nice mess she would put
everything back in order and put it away
so we could get back to it when we
needed it and the lawyer I don't think
the lawyer on this book changed more
than ten words and I know that several
times when he got to a prayer of oh yeah
wrong verb fix that right now do you
have any worried you have to have an
insurance policy to protect you well
publisher has an insurance policy if
Donald's going to sue me he's going to
sue me I was actually surprised Donald
said that to me because we've known each
other he knows I don't intimidate he's
tried to intimidate me in the past I
mean I'm a guy who hunted down an
especially vicious murderer in a black
on white murder I'd run into a burning
building I mean maybe I was scurrilous
somewhere that I don't have out of the
way in Mountain View California why did
you do that get a better picture I also
ran towards two buildings people were in
but they got out of them before I got
there thank goodness but you know you do
what you need to do in your job and my
job is to tell
people facts they wouldn't know but for
my work so you know I've been tailed by
the LAPD by the government and Taiwan
or people connected with it I've had
lots of people threaten me you know it's
it's my job and you do what you need to
do or you don't do the kind of work that
I do so anyway the the lawyer changed
very little in this book on contrast to
that I wrote a piece for political
magazine that's what Donald called me
about which had nothing new in it it
simply pointed out a number not all of
them of his connections to criminals his
business dealings with him and his
gratuitous connections to them that is
the most heavily Lawyer piece of my
career with maybe one exception and I've
written stories accusing people of
murder you know Jack Welch gave up his
retirement benefits over a story I wrote
and that lawyer ring told me that he's
really been intimidating news
organizations and threatening the Silman
well they know that he can't win he can
cost them a lot of money the former CEO
of GE Jack Welsh did what that he gave
up his retirement benefit Jack Welch had
a retirement package that was described
in to the investors only as mr. Welch
shall continue to receive those
emoluments he had wealth serving the
company then he left his wife and she a
litigator put into the public record
enough information that I was able to
show that he was going to get what I
estimate to be about 70 million dollars
of the use of a GE jet apartments
ballgame tickets and stuff whether you
use them or not and I laid out the
economics in particular of the corporate
jet and Welch then wrote an article in
The Wall Street Journal relinquishing
all of this and saying that some people
who don't respect contracts I respect
his contract I just thought investors
should know what they were actually
paying Jack Welch and I know from
something he said to another journalist
that he's furious with the mention of my
name
he's entitled I cost him a lot of money
back to down Korea in the book you talk
about an outfit called awards or the
Academy of hospitality services in
Academy of hospitality service or
Sciences I think this is an organization
run by
convicted art thief and mob associate
known as Joey to socks
Joseph sink and it hands out what it
says is the most prestigious award in
the world not the most prestigious
travel industry award the most
prestigious award in the world
it's the Five Diamond Award and the six
Diamond Award and at least nineteen
Trump properties have these awards on a
big huge plaques on the wall and they're
signed by Joey to socks and they're also
signed by the chairman of the board of
the Academy Donald J Trump Donald Trump
gives awards to himself there are video
on the Internet you can see of this I
mean this absurd giving an award to
yourself it works well apparently a lot
of people think these are fabulous
properties I point out that a couple of
his golf courses have awards and yet if
you look at the golf digest or golf
magazine that forget which one list of
100 best golf courses no Trump golf
courses on that list what's he do well
well the first and foremost Donald is a
masterful at making himself a household
name I mean you went on television for
years you're not a household name Brian
and neither am i but Donald is a
household name I mean that's a quite
accomplishment he secondly has created
this image of himself as the modern
Midas everything he touches turns to
gold and in fact a lot of it turns to
dross and the only person who ends up
with any gold is Donald he also has been
successful in getting even Network
television in America to run stories
that in essence he is the Don Juan of
our age and that women like Madonna and
Kim Basinger and Carla Bruni are
pounding on his bedroom door by the way
he doesn't even know two of them the
third one says he's the king of sleaze
and had nothing to do with him she's
talked to him apparently twice in her
life Carla Carla Bruni
married to Sarkozy and Rice and when she
became the first lady of France Donald
had the opportunity when he was on the
Howard Stern Show as I report in the
making of Donald Trump to back away from
these imaginary lover stories that he
planted and he didn't and but he's very
good at planting these stories so the
people have an image of him that has
nothing to do I think with the reality
of who he is his building at Trump Tower
that's that's quite a building it's a
significant accomplishment where is it
it's on Fifth Avenue
Manhattan right in the middle of the
city now it's 58 stories he tells
everybody at 68 that's part of how
Donald exaggerated things those are
things that I think he's accomplished
done done very well but his companies
are very poorly managed
Fortune magazine looked at his casino
company there was a public company and
concluded that of the 496 companies they
studied Donald Canyon dead last
or almost last in every single category
this is no surprise to people who worked
for Donald and competitors so he does
another area where he's great at
creating this image of himself that
doesn't comport with reality go back to
the carla bruni story what's the rest of
it what how did he get in the middle of
it well when Donald was divorcing his
first wife Ivana he went out of his way
to publicly humiliate the mother of his
children he planted all sorts of news
stories that there was a competition
going on in the Madonna and Kim Basinger
and carla bruni and other women were
trying to become the next mrs. Trump and
it was it and he used a PR man named
John Baron John Barron was Donald Trump
he called up these news organizations
and they didn't know who he was he
wasn't as well known at the time to pose
as this PR man promoting Trump and
People magazine outed him at the time
we've got a clip sue Carswell is the one
that wrote the piece and rifle it and it
how it was back in 1991 90 or 91 yes
yeah
91 so when we're listening to this and
there'll be language on the screen that
is Donald Trump masquerading as either
John Baron or John Miller absolutely
absolutely that's Donald and they outed
him in a story where they make fun of
him because here's a middle-aged man
acting like a 13 year old boy talking
about some girl he was with it's just
extraordinary there's just a little bit
of this it starts off slow but you'll be
able to hear it right right away he was
going to name a John Miller then it did
she know that was downtown
well she figuring it out very quickly
she had not covered him but he displayed
such intimate conversation for the
freshly hired PR person and talked in
such detail that it was clear it was
done
and People magazine REM this piece
saying something like there are odd
stories there are unusual stories there
are funny stories and then there's this
really bizarre story how long did he do
that go under four years four years he
did that with the USFL he would call up
journalists and planets GSM the United
States Football League that was the
spring football league which I point out
in the book he basically destroyed with
a litigation strategy instead of a
market strategy and he would call up
news organizations sometimes two
different reporters and he would be John
Baron or John Miller and then he would
calls himself and verify the story to
get it planted he he did this he got a
story planted that way in the New York
Times about the USFL the Football League
he he also used it to menace to threaten
people with litigation that they didn't
back off in particular there were about
150 to 200 illegal immigrants from
Poland who were demolishing the Bonwit
teller department store where the site
which is now Trump Tower they were being
paid $4 an hour they slept on the site
in the middle of winter because they had
nowhere else to go
they didn't have hard hats or goggles or
any safety equipment and then they
didn't get paid until they threatened to
hang Donald's overseer off the side of
the building because they hadn't gotten
paid and Donald was later found by a
federal judge to have engaged in a
conspiracy to cheat the workers out of
their money $4 an hour and he's not
paying people Bulgari yes what is it and
what's the story
well Bulgari is a high-end Italian
jewelry company with stores all over the
world including across the street from
Trump Tower and Donald Trump engaged in
something known as the empty box scam
he bought a fifty thousand dollar piece
of jewelry and then a fifteen thousand
dollar piece and he had them shipped out
of state that if they were shipped out
of state to a non-resident of New York
there would be no sales tax - there
might be used tax due in that state that
that's not enforced very much and Donald
was not eligible for this because he
lived in New York he lived right across
the street when law enforcement got on
to this and the New York Attorney
General Robert Abrams
began investigating bottle got when to
this now he had a casino license and his
involvement in any crime would vitiate
his license so Donald went to law
enforcement to help them and he wasn't
the only one involved Mary Tyler Moore
Henry Kissinger were involved in this
it's a scam that's gone on for decades
it continues to go on there's a case
right now about this if those people
know it was illegal order of course they
do and and the Bulgari was so cheap in
doing this but instead of paying the
postage for what the wait would be of
the jewelry they saved a little bit of
money by sending empty boxes with no
weight but the significance of the story
is it's clear evidence of Donald
participating in tax cheating and that
should have cost him his casino license
had the state of New Jersey had any
interest in tightening up and enforcing
the law that required Donald's and all
other casino owners to prove by clear
and convincing evidence that they are
morally fit they're honest they don't
associate with criminals so if you were
with some of your friends and Donald
Trump was elected president and you're
sitting around talking and all of a
sudden you look up on the screen the
winner is Donald Trump what's the first
thing you'd say them I'd say well how
long until we have a constitutional
crisis Donald does not understand the
powers limits and duties of our
president under the Constitution he
talks like the president is a dictator
he has said he will order our military
to engage in illegal acts and if you're
a senior United States military officer
my guess is you are reading up very
carefully on how you refuse an unlawful
order from the commander-in-chief in
order to use nuclear weapons in Europe
where our friends are at which Donald
has talked about in order to torture
people you know we executed Japanese
soldiers after World War two for
waterboarding and that would be the the
big concern the second one would be if
Donald's presidency on States I'm
absolutely certain that I will have
trouble with somebody in federal law
enforcement he will find some way to
make my life difficult because that's
about this Donald's philosophy which
he's written about a great length and
spoken about and lectured about and
interviewed about is get revenge
destroy anybody if someone just
won't do you a favor destroy their life
and take pleasure in that that should
make you really really happy he says
when he destroys people's lies it just
makes him so happy
so I if you get selected I'm going to
have trouble what would you say this
same group if Hillary Clinton is elected
um you know I haven't thought a lot
about that I mean you know Hillary
Clinton like John Kasich is competent to
be President she knows what the job
isn't how to do it I I don't see any
tension she's going to pursue policies
that are inimical to the long-term
interests of the country I don't like a
lot of her policies but but you're going
to investigative reporter and you must
have looked at what's going on with the
foundation and all no and the reason is
I can't do everything
I don't know Hillary Clinton when I left
the LA Times if I had gone to Little
Rock I have you write in the book about
Hillary Clinton there's a lot there I
went to Atlantic City and I met Donald
Trump there are good books about Hillary
Clinton well-written books is also some
garbage on both of them but there's some
well-written books and I encourage
people in my book to go read those books
I've written about Hillary Clinton twice
in my life and never spoken to her
anybody on her staff in 1997 in The New
York Times I pointed out that the
Clintons paid more than twice as much
federal income taxes the law required
despite spending almost 9,000 ten
thousand dollars a year having their tax
returns prepared and it was because she
mishandled as a tax matter the royalties
from her book it takes a village she
said she'd give them all away well she
took them as income paid the taxes and
gave away the difference she was furious
about this she went absolutely nuts
about it the New York Times actually
didn't publish my story the first year
so I had to wait a year and redo it
after I had some editors lined up about
it
and then the next year I went to the
White House to get the president's tax
returns and I said up there's nothing
here about the new book what is it and I
think Jodie Enda from Knight Ridder
hollowed out letters to buddy in socks
and I go yeah about the pets and the
spokesman says well the Clintons gave
the copyright to a public charity which
was the implicit advice in my story and
I said oh really
and the spokesman said yes and the White
House wants to be on record that the
Clinton
did not take their advice from the New
York Times which point everybody erupted
laughter because they obviously did that
and it meant more money for charity and
less for the government how many years
Whitney where you live the New York
Times what was your beat and when did
you leave it I was with the New York
Times for 13 years I left in April of
2008 I came there to show that we could
cover taxes in a different way and
examine how the system actually works as
opposed to what politicians and others
say about it which is why I did it out
of New York and my home in Rochester New
York not Washington I also changed the
way all journalists cover executive
compensation by showing things that were
right in front of us that we weren't
paying attention to and but principally
I did I did taxes and you know as
measured by Congress my work resulted in
over a quarter trillion dollars of tax
dodges being stopped and a lot of people
went to prison the biggest while the
biggest was President Bush had in his
tax plan that he wouldn't show us before
the election a stealth provision that
would allow very very Eisen by president
george w bush in his tax plan there was
a I called stealth provision because he
wouldn't show us the plan before the
election that would repeal the gift tax
and that was an idea that conservative
Republicans put into the law in the
1920s and when the White House was the
White House press secretary Ari
Fleischer was asked about this he
expressed that you know I knew my stuff
about taxes and then they quietly
withdrew this provision that Congress
later staff reports show that would have
cost just in the first ten years about a
quarter of a billion a trillion dollars
quarter of a trillion dollars and that
was the Bermuda mailbox scam and a lot
of other professor small dok2 teaches
tax law Duke has called me the de facto
chief tax enforcement officer of the
United States and he told the media for
restarting you got a book you're
planning on taxes yes the book I was
working on when I dropped for this is
tentatively called the prosperity tax an
entirely new federal tax code for the
21st century economy we have a really
great tax system in America for 1960 and
we no longer live in the US
your age we have an industrial age tax
system and we need to have a tax system
for the current economy and this book
will have the actual statutory language
I'm not a lawyer but I've learned how to
write that story language and I expect
it to be less than 100 pages and it will
it uses things that are all in them
already there's virtually there's only
one thing I have in there that's not
already in the law it's much simpler
very few people will have to file a tax
return nobody has to there's a group
that can choose to corporations will
have a much easier time it'll be much
more efficient we can shrink the IRS
down and I've set up a mechanism by
which if you want to cheat on your taxes
you have to engage in a criminal
conspiracy with the other person the
other person is liable for the taxes and
you're both going to go to prison
what's that publishing time for this
well if I am NOT teaching this year so I
can finish it so I'm hoping the book
will be out in 2018 speaking of tax how
much tax as Donald Trump paid from what
you know well we know as a matter of
fact that he paid no income taxes in 78
79 80 for 92 and 94 we know that in
recent years his adjusted gross income
that's the last line of the front page
year tax churn was less than $500,000
now the tax law has all sorts of
provisions that allow some people at the
top to live tax free or virtually tax
free private equity managers like Mitt
Romney hedge fund managers and people
who are full-time real estate
professionals like Donald Trump there is
good reason to believe because of those
rules that Donald probably has paid no
income taxes or maybe a couple years a
little bit since 1978 and do you think
he will release those returned yes never
not a chance it is never going to happen
and when Donald and his son say there's
nothing there there's nothing there you
couldn't tell anything from Texans you
give me Donald Trump's complete tax
return for one year and I'll back
engineer and tell you the value of his
hard assets I'll tell you where his
income sources I'll tell a lot about him
you mentioned earlier about Donald's
religion Donald Trump's religion excuse
me and also is a Bible reading here's
Jerry Falwell Jr who spoke at the
convention this year on his behalf and
has been supporting him yeah well you
know I've known and spent time with
mobsters who were good family men I mean
out that part doesn't impress me what
troubles me are the pastors who were
saying that Donald Trump is a good
Christian man Donald Trump in his own
words is aggressively antithetical to
Christianity
first of all he denigrates communion
well you get your little water and your
little cracker when he's asked as he's
been many times to cite a favorite
passage from the Bible because he says
nobody reads the book the Bible more
than Donald Trump he gives a conman
answer well there's so many there's
somebody there's just so many and the
one time he tried which I recount in the
book he got it wrong and it was out of
Leviticus knife or an eye and he didn't
even understand what that concept actual
means I'm sorry in Sermon on the Mount
Matthew 5 especially Matthew 5:39 245
Jesus's message was you turn the other
cheek you were kind to other people
God rejects that he says he says of
people who do that you're fools you're
idiots you're Schmucks and you can just
do it in passing this is not a gap this
is a well established record so to the
pastors who are endorsing Donald Trump
if they want to endorse him and say look
he's better than the other person I
think probably that that makes perfect
sense
but do not deceive your flocks do not
allow this man to beguile you with
flattery do not tell people this
falsehood and I've emailed a couple of
them and offered my book on a short
description of what's there only one got
back to me through an assistant to
basically say well thanks if we want to
know anything we'll get in touch with
you ministers have an absolute duty not
to deceive their flocks and not to tell
them that a man whose own lengthy
statements and actions are aggressively
anti the message of Jesus Christ is a
good Christian man and to vote for him
for that reason that's that's an awful
development and I want to these pastors
called to account they're the members of
their flocks and other religious leaders
should be raising Cain about this given
expensive why Jerry followed
you're supporting me they have the
largest I believe Christian University
in the United States with their online
service well I I hope that's because
he's badly informed that's my hope
my concern is that he's more interested
in political outcomes than he is in
following the message of Jesus Christ
you have a story in your book about a
man named satyr SAT TRS excuse me a
trader
SAT ter but you say sometimes his name
was spelt SAT er Felix seder is the son
of the reputed Russian mob boss who by
the way is threatened now twice to sue
me over writing about him he was Donald
Trump's senior advisor he had a business
card senior advisor to Donald Trump he
had at his office was right in the main
suite of Trump Organization offices in
Trump Tower he and Donald traveled all
over together Loveland Colorado Denver
Phoenix Fort Lauderdale New York they
were involved in putting building
projects together
Felix aider is a defendant in a private
attorney general action in the state of
New York
accusing him of running a quarter
billion dollar tax fraud and only an
accusation it is a tax fraud that could
not have taken place but for a letter
that Donald Trump signed that authorized
changes that made it possible in this
tax fraud goes through Icelandic banks
to Russian oligarchs and a Felix aider
is a convicted violent felon he put a
the broken end of a margarita stem glass
so deeply into a man's face it took 110
stitches in his face will never be right
and he's a convicted stock swindler with
the help of four mob families in New
York he ran a 40 million dollar stocks
game that he's pled guilty to Donald is
not supposed to be when he had a casino
associating with these folks secondly
they're borrowing money from banks and
they hid this the reason Felix aider
sometimes put an extra T in his name was
so journalists and others wouldn't find
out about his background Donald Trump
had a duty to investors and the bankers
he borrowed from to inquire into this
man's background
he didn't or
he didn't want to and he has told I
think it was the AAP Jason Horowitz has
been a very good job at the AAP I think
was the one he said this to he said I
hardly know the man if he was in the
room I wouldn't recognize him I've got
video and photographs and interviews
they did together and that's absurd he
knows this guy very very well
and this is part of these not fully
developed understanding we have of
Donald's connection to the Putin regime
and to the Russian oligarchs that should
be very much the subject of a lot of
inquiry by my peers they should be
deeply digging into what is what is it
the Donald Trump is advancing the
primary foreign policy objective of
Vladimir Putin weaken NATO he won't say
a single critical word about him he's
been paid millions of dollars by Russian
oligarchs he's boasted I I had every one
of them in a room in Moscow was eight
years ago he's tried to do all sorts of
deals in Russia there's a forty seven
story building in one of the former
Soviet empire countries with his name on
it and there is this tax this alleged
tax fraud and stater is at the center of
all of this what is Donald Trump doing
spending years in very close
relationship with this convicted violent
felon in stock swindler and they're a
bunch of lawsuits about it including
hiding this man's criminal background
from investors that damage their
interests as a result what Marx would
you give your peers that you mentioned
well overall I think the American news
media has done an awful job now I know
some people listening to this tour
meeting saying well nobody bedded Barack
Obama actually they did he just have to
go look and read the news about it I
mean I know about women he dated and
kids he went to grammar school with and
high school with and lots about Barack
Obama what his professors said about him
and fellow students at Columbia and at
Harvard where he was incredibly highly
regarded this is an example of this in
Donald Trump's case you're only now
starting to see an inquiry into them now
the Washington Post had about twenty
reporters on this and I helped them with
some things I gave them documents and
stuff as I often do for other reporters
which most journalists ought to but I do
and they've done some pretty good
stories but they're written in the way
that highbrow newspapers now do this so
that unless you're a sophisticated
reader you don't get the point The Wall
Street Journal has done nothing of any
consequence the New York Times has
recently done some very good stories but
the same thing they've written this very
highbrow fashion that you can easily not
grasp what's going on what about
television absolutely appalling Brian
I've been on the national networks
broadcast networks in Australia Canada
Britain France Germany repeatedly I
haven't been on a single u.s. broadcast
network none of the Sunday morning talk
shows they've had people on who don't
know what anything talking about things
about Donald Trump and speculating when
I could give them hard facts and where
do you think they're doing it well first
of all and most importantly Donald Trump
is great television I mean you can't
turn it off and Fox News has said you
know that when they turn off or one of
their agents has said when they turn
when the major not Donald Trump people
turn their TVs off it's like it's like
not just watching a car wreck it's like
watching this incredible car wreck and
so people want to see it so there is a
commercial interest secondly newsrooms
have been shrunk anonymously I mean
basically the fastest disappearing
white-collar job in America in the last
15 years has been journalists and the
resources aren't there I once spent
$10,000 of the Los Angeles Times as
money on one paragraph today to get
$10,000 to do a story you'd have to
really convince editors that was
something substantial there and then I
think more importantly the duty of
journalists which is to tell you that
which people don't want to tell you has
been in decline because of all the
attacks from people who don't want to
hear things and they mount attacks and
both have left them to write about this
here's his dad this is 1985 getting a
her out Rachel Alger award in New York I
remember read that Shakespeare baby
that's there but Fred Trump was an
incredibly industrious guy he was really
hard-working but he also was a guy who
profiteer Don GI housing
to the war and President Eisenhower when
he found out that Fred Trump had four
million dollars of excess profits threw
a fit in the White House and the proof
of that is a hundred federal
investigators are put on Fred Trump and
a few other developers and when he was
hauled before the Senate Finance
Committee you know and this is
indicative of the future under Donald
Trump he said well this is all just a
misunderstanding
I didn't profiteer I haven't taken any
money before I guess I have four million
dollars more but but it's in bank I
didn't take it so I'm not profiteer
and and the Fred Trump honest well let's
see
they color-coded applications for
rentals so when a black or puerto rican
renter would show up with solid finances
to rent an apartment they would be
steered to a building for blacks or
puerto ricans they would be steered away
from Beach Haven and I have the lyrics
to a song about Fred Trump's racism by
Woody Guthrie because of the generosity
of the Guthrie family in the book and
and he was well known for his
association with the mob guys for Willy
Tomasello his partner who was a mob
associate speaking of that there is a
documentary that has been held up for a
long time and here's an excerpt other
this thing is called Trump what's the
deal you can buy it on youtube for two
dollars and ninety five cents you'll
read I think you run for that buy it for
about ten well I mean you can watch it
yeah to dine fight but here's just a
little excerpt I want you to explain it
after we just see this so what happened
to the Taj Mahal and what about this
documentary well I covered all of that
back then and these were terrible deals
i wrote that they were both going to
fail promptly and they couldn't pay
their bond interest which is exactly
what happened this documentary by Livy
Hondros was a terrific job of telling
you who Donald Trump was it was only
shown twice and Donald's threats of
litigation shut it down Donald has shut
down many things with threats of
litigation I wrote a proposal for a Tim
Burton movie about Donald Trump and his
threats of litigation meant that it
never came about
finally Libby Hondros decided when he
was running for president I've got to
put this out there they updated it just
a little bit in the opening because
people need to see this and it's 80
minutes and it's a
great quick lesson on bomb drop I'd
rather you buy my book but Libby's movie
is always very good this particular deal
was indicative of the fact that Donald
doesn't have the business skill he says
he has he cannibalized his own market he
took over this this white elephant of a
property the Trump Taj Mahal his name
will now disappear on October 10th from
Atlantic City because his casinos are
gone and he goes around saying that it's
terrible from the Atlantic City what do
you know there are casinos in Atlantic
City this day were making nice fat
profits above average profits for the
country for all businesses why didn't he
because he was a his company was
terribly managed when he had competent
executives three of them are killed the
helicopter crash unfortunately but every
other case he eventually drove out his
competent executives because he was
demanding and bullying and mistreated
people and if you're competent you know
what are you gonna put up with this for
you go somewhere else and he put in
place yes ma'am and by the way to your
earlier question a Donald Trump
administration will be full of people
many of them you've probably never heard
of who's distinguishing characteristic
will be total loyalty to Donald Trump
not to the Constitution not to the
American people not to the long-term
welfare of the country but to Donald
Trump personal we're running out of time
and I got a couple more names I want to
bring up Bob
Liberty is that Bob low buddy was the
Biggest Loser in Atlantic City he was a
con man and a mob guy not a made guy but
a mob associate who I spent a lot of
time with and Donald was fined for
removing black women and Asian dealers
and cocktail waitresses because he
thought it was currying favor with Bob
because Bob when he was losing money
would let loose this just vile language
crazy language in many cases and Bob low
buddy when I entered him because hey I
didn't know Donald was doing that that's
outrageous I would never remove somebody
you know I say these terrible words but
but you know I'm not the racist Donald
Trump is the racist Bob Lowe buddy calls
you a racist that's pretty Pat where is
he now he's dead he he died a few years
ago Donald tried to seduce his daughter
and Steve hide who was
in the casinos it was very competent
told Bob Labbadia who told the story to
me you got to keep Donald away from your
daughter because you're going to kill
him and I'm going to lose my best
customer and Bob as he told the story to
me wet to Donald and said after Donald
had given her cream-colored Mercedes and
had a video made for her birthday and
other things that if you approached my
daughter again I will castrate you
without benefit of a knife by the way
you mentioned in the book about his
germophobia yeah and now he's shaking
hands yeah I don't know that's very
interesting I actually did shake hands
with Donald once a long long time ago
and I noticed it was immediately you
know doing this and disappeared into the
bathroom but he's now shaking hands I
think somebody has told him doesn't look
good if you don't do that I'm going to
let you pronounce the name Akio
Kashiwagi
Akio Kashiwagi was the biggest gambler
in the world and I'm the only journalist
who watched him gamble at the rate of
fourteen million dollars an hour two
hundred thousand dollars about seventy
bucks an hour and Donald Trump lured him
twice to Atlantic City he completely
mishandled this guy he should have won
twelve million dollars off of them and
instead he lost about six and I recount
in the book the story of what happened
here and Donald hired of Jeff's Markham
who was a teenager helped invent radar
and went on to be a co-founder of the
RAND Corporation one of the great
geniuses of the last century to watch
the game because he was convinced the
guy was cheating and I recounted the
story that I'm the person who figured
out there was a half million dollars of
chips missing that nobody else noticed
and it turned out that Kashiwagi had in
fact scammed him for the half million
dollars with the chips but the story is
mostly about how if Donald had
understood the game of baccarat and the
math he would have realized that there
came a point when it was an 87 to one
odds that he would wipe the guy out and
instead he gave him the excuse to walk
away from the table and Donald lost
money as a result and that's indicative
of the fact that Donald just doesn't
know anything I would go back to the
lawyers in this book what did they or
did they execute
editing I mean I've been doing this for
so many years almost 50 years now that I
know how to write things so that they're
legal and they're fair how did you get
on the New York Times bestseller list
a lot of people bought the book how did
they find out about it television hasn't
had well because I have a pretty
good-sized Twitter following
they Melville House is very good at
marketing and they were out telling
people about the book the initial orders
we got from bookstores were just nothing
because they're a bunch of Trump books
and I my fear was what would happen to
my last two bestsellers they ran out of
books well that happened a lot of
bookstores ran out of books so first
weekend and then they started ordering
lots of books so it's now readily
available but that was just devastating
to me the first time around I'm going up
the New York Times bestseller list and
then have enough books this time the the
people of Melville House have been
extraordinary in their understanding of
how you market a book and get people to
buy it was there any other title beside
the making of Donald Trump I wanted to
call the book the art of deception they
want to do that that's not a neutral
title it and it turns people off I've
actually had people post things on the
internet because they think this is a
pro Donald Trump book and it was
designed to be neutral and to tell you
what it's about and it's essentially
where does this guy come from who is he
and it's I start with you know his
grandfather who was a German draft
dodger who made a fortune running
whorehouses on through Donald's
development in his education and then
all of these associations that he
doesn't want you to know about and my
goal was to balance Donald Trump's
masterful PR image of himself with all
the things Donald does not want you to
know